thank you all for being on time uh you  have no idea how hello  hi  hello  my name jeff hi jeff welcome to  english 204 late romanticism  my frogs are sleeping stop being so loud  everything  everything okay over there shut up my  dad my frogs are sleeping professor i  think he's pranking you  jeff or i love mom more than oh my oh my  god okay okay okay i i i read about  these uh how do i push the block that's  why mom left do you like jazz no no no  jeff i'm sending new codes right now i'm  going to close the meeting just uh  look at your email check your email  william blake differed from shelley in  more ways than one bubba booey baba  booey baba booey baba boo boo he worked  primarily as a printmaker